HERE IN THE UNITED STATES AND
AROUND THE WORLD.
IT IS THURSDAY, SEPTEMBER 23rd.
AND DIVE TEAMS WILL BE BACK IN
THE WATER TODAY NEAR THE FLORIDA
HOME OF BRIAN LAUNDRIE.
THE FIANCEE OF 22-YEAR-OLD GABBY
PETITO HAS NOT BEEN SEEN NOW FOR
NEARLY TWO WEEKS SINCE RETURNING
HOME FROM THEIR ROAD TRIP ALONE.
A LARGE BOAT ARRIVED MIDDAY
WEDNESDAY IN A SWAMPY 25,000
ACRE RESERVE WHERE LAUNDRIE TOLD
HIS PARENTS HE WAS HEADED LAST
WEEK.
AFTER FOUR DAYS OF SEARCHING,
THERE IS STILL NO SIGN OF HIM
>> NEW CLUES WHAT MAY HAVE BEEN
THE FINAL HOURS OF PETITO'S
LIFE.
A COUPLE WHO SAID THEY WITNESSED
AN INCIDENT INVOLVING PETITO AND
LAUNDRIE IN A RESTAURANT.
IT MAY HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE LAST
SIGHTINGS OF GABBY BEFORE HER
DEATH.
THE COUPLE REPORTS SEEING A
COMMOTION THAT HAD PETITO
VISIBLY UPSET
>> AMARA WALKER IS ON THE STORY
FOR US IN VENICE, FLORIDA, WITH
THE LATEST ON THE SEARCH FOR
BRIAN LAUNDRIE.
AMARA, WHAT ARE YOU HEARING?
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING TO YOU
BOTH.
YEAH, YESTERDAY A SPECIALIZED
TEAM OF DIVERS WAS ON SCENE ALL
DAY.
BUT WE'RE TOLD THEIR SEARCH
TURNED UP NOTHING.
SO LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL BE
RESUMING THAT SEARCH HERE AT THE
CARLTON RESERVE FOR BRIAN
LAUNDRIE.
AND THEY SAY THEY ARE TRYING TO
COVER EVERY ACRE.
STILL NO SIGNS OF BRIAN LAUNDRIE
THIS MORNING, AS INVESTIGATORS
EXPAND THE URGENT SEARCH FOR
GABBY PETITO'S FIANCEE
>> WE HAVE DEPLOYED NUMEROUS
RESOURCES.
WE ARE TRYING TO COVER EVERY
ACRE IN THIS RESERVE.
>> Reporter: AUTHORITIES USING
CANINES TO HELP SEARCH ON THE
GROUND AND FLYING DRONES OVER
THE 25,000 ACRES OF SWAMPLANDS
OF THIS FLORIDA NATURE RESERVE.
SPECIALIZED UNDER WATER DIVE
TEAMS ARRIVING TO ASSIST WHILE
HIGH-WATER VEHICLES NAVIGATE
THROUGH WAIST-DEEP WATER.
>> PHYSICAL SEARCHES LIKE THAT
AND THAT TYPE OF REMOTE WERE
AREA PRESENT ALL KINDS OF
PROBLEMS.
IT'S A MARSHY AREA.
IT'S THICK WITH FOLIAGE.
IT'S VERY HARD TO GET INTO
CERTAIN SPOTS.
>> Reporter: LAUNDRIE GOING
MISSING AFTER RETURNING TO THE
FAMILY HOME THE COUPLE SHARED
WITH HIS PARENTS WITHOUT PETITO
SEPTEMBER 1st.
THE FBI IS ASKING THE PUBLIC TO
HELP FIND LAUNDRIE.
>> IT IS USUALLY A SIGN THAT YOU
HAVE A VERY CHALLENGING MANHUNT
ON YOUR HANDS.
>> Reporter: THEY ARE ALSO
SEEKING ASSISTANCE TO PIECE
TOGETHER THE TIMELINE OF
PETITO'S FINAL DAYS.
AUGUST 12th, PETITO SHARING THIS
PHOTO ON INSTAGRAM.
THAT'S THE SAME DAY A WITNESS
DIALED 911 TO REPORT A DOMESTIC
DISPUTE BETWEEN HER AND
LAUNDRIE, PROMPTING POLICE TO
PULL THEM OVER.
>> WE HAVE BEEN FIGHTING ALL
MORNING.
>> Reporter: ONE WEEK LATER --
>> I LOVE THE VAN.
>> Reporter: THE COUPLE POSTING
THIS VIDEO ON THEIR YOUTUBE
PAGE, DOCUMENTING THEIR CROSS
COUNTRY JOURNEY.
JESSICA SCHULTZ TEN TELLING THE
"SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE" SHE
SAW LAUNDRIE A WEEK LATER IN HIS
VAN, CLOSE TO WHERE THEY FOUND
PETITO'S REMAINS.
>> I WAS CHECKING OUT TO SEE IF
IT WAS A COUPLE OR SOLO DUDE.
IT WAS A SOLO DUDE AS FAR AS I
COULD SEE.
>> Reporter: YOUTUBE BLOGGERS
ALSO SAY SHE SPOTTED THE
VEHICLE.
SHE SAW HIM IN JACKS SON,
WYOMING THAT DAY, DESCRIBING A
COMMOTION WHERE PETITO WAS IN
TEARS AND LAUNDRIE WAS VISIBLY
ANGRY.
>> SHE WAS HYSTERICALLY CRYING.
AND SHE WALKED OUT AND SHE WAS
CRYING AND STANDING ON THE
SIDEWALK.
AND I WAS WATCHING THE WHOLE
THING UNFOLD.
HE WALKED IN FOUR MORE TIMES TO
TALK TO THE MANAGER AND TELL THE
HOSTESS.
>> Reporter: THE SAME DAY AND
AFFIDAVIT THAT PETITO'S MOTHER
RECEIVED AN ODD TEXT FROM HER
DAUGHTER'S PHONE THAT REFERRED
TO HER GRANDFATHER MY STAN,
WHICH SHE NEVER DID.
WITNESS TIPS CAN HELP MOVE A
PROBE FURTHER.
>> RIGHT NOW THE FOCUS HAS TO BE
ON TRYING TO LOCATE HIM, DEAD OR
ALIVE.
>> Reporter: SO THE FBI OF
COURSE IS FOCUSED RIGHT NOW ON
FINDING BRIAN LAUNDRIE.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO FOCUSED ON THIS
TIMELINE FROM AUGUST 27th TO THE
30th.
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
BETWEEN GABBY PETITO AND BRIAN
LAUNDRIE.
THEY ARE ASKING ANYONE WHO MAY
HAVE HAD CONTACT WITH THEM OR
EVEN JUST SAW THEIR SEEK IN THE
GRAND TETON NATIONAL PARK TO
GIVE THEM A CALL.
BRIANNA.
>> AMARA WALKER, THANK YOU FOR
THAT REPORT.
>>> I WANT TO BRING IN ANDREW
McCABE, FORMER DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR AND AUTHOR OF THE "THE
THREAT HOW THE THREAT PROTECTS
AMERICA IN THE AGE OF TERROR AND
TRUMP."
THIS NEW BIT OF REPORTING FROM
RANDI KAYE WHO HAS BEEN OUT IN
WYOMING, THIS RESTAURANT, WHERE
A COUPLE SAW, YOU KNOW, A HEATED
EXCHANGE BETWEEN BRIAN LAUNDRIE.
GABBY PETITO PHYSICALLY UPSET.
MAY HAVE BEEN THE LAST TIME
ANYONE SAW HER ALIVE.
HOW DOES THAT FIT INTO THE
PUZZLE FOR INVESTIGATORS?
>> JOHN, THESE REPORTS ARE
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL TO
INVESTIGATORS PRIMARILY BECAUSE
THEY PUT THE VICTIM AND THE
POTENTIAL SUBJECT IN A
DEFINITIVE PLACE AT A SPECIFIC
TIME.
SO THAT HELPS THEM BUILD THIS
TIMELINE TO KIND OF BRIDGE BACK
TO THAT MOMENT OF WHEN GABBY WAS
KILLED.
AS FOR THE KIND OF PERSONAL
REMEMBRANCES OF PEOPLE WHO MAY
HAVE SEEN THEIR INTERACTION,
THAT BECOMES LESS HELPFUL.
WE ALL KNOW THAT EYEWITNESS
TESTIMONY IS TYPICALLY -- CAN BE
VERY INACCURATE.
PEOPLE'S REMEMBRANCES OF THINGS
CHANGE OVER TIME.
BEING ABLE TO PIN THEM DOWN A
LOT A PARTICULAR DAY IN TIME IS
VERY HELPFUL.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
SEARCH FOR BRIAN LAUNDRIE.
THEY KEEP GOING BACK TO THE
NATURE PRESERVE.
NOW THEY HAVE DIVERS SEARCHING
UNDER WATER.
DO THEY HAVE TO HAVE SOME SIGN
OF SHRED OF EVIDENCE TO KEEP ON
DOING THIS, OR IS THIS JUST
HOPING FOR SOMETHING?
>> YOU KNOW, LAW ENFORCEMENT ON
THE SCENE HAS BEEN VERY
DEFINITIVE SAYING THEY WILL
SEARCH EVERY ACRE OF THAT
PROPERTY.
25,000 ACRES.
THAT IS APPROXIMATELY 40 SQUARE
MILES OF TURF THEY'VE GOT TO
COVER.
THEY ARE AT 80 MILES OF HIKING
TRAILS WITHIN THAT PARK.
IT'S A BIG PLACE.
AT SOME POINT IF THEY FIND NO
SIGN OF RYAN WHATSOEVER, THEY
WILL HAVE TO REDIRECT THE
RESOURCES TO OTHER INVESTIGATIVE
EFFORTS.
>> HOW HARD WOULD IT BE IF HE
WERE TO BE ON THE RUN RIGHT NOW?
HOW LONG COULD SOMEONE LIKE THAT
DO IT, DO YOU THINK?
>> IT'S INCREDIBLY HARD TO BE ON
THE RUN.
I CAN TELL YOU IN MY 21 YEARS IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE FBI, I
HAVE SEEN VERY FEW PEOPLE DO IT
SUCCESSFULLY FOR A LONG TIME.
YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT WHITEY
BULGER, ERIC ROBERT RUDOLPH, THE
OLYMPIC PARK BOMBER, WHO LIVED
IN THE WOODS FIVE YEARS BEFORE
WE FOUND HIM.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE MONEY, YOU HAVE
TO HAVE SUPPORT FROM YOUR
FAMILY, FROM THE COMMUNITY, AND
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A DEEP LEVEL OF
KIND OF CUNNING AND STREET
SMARTS TO BE ABLE TO KIND OF
BRIDGE FROM ONE PLACE TO THE
NEXT.
THERE IS NO INDICATION THAT
BRIAN LAUNDRIE HAS ANY OF THOSE
THINGS WORKING TO HIS ADVANTAGE
AT THIS POINT.
AND IF HE'S, IN FACT, IN THAT
RESERVE, THAT IS AN INCREDIBLY
HARSH ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH TO
TRY TO SUSTAIN YOURSELF.
.
>> YOU BROUGHT UP THE FAMILY
THERE.
WE HAVE NO INDICATION THAT THE
FBI IS INVESTIGATING THE PARENTS
OR THE FAMILY IN CONNECTION WITH
ANY OF THIS.
BUT YOU BROUGHT UP ERIC RUDOLPH,
WHITEY BULGER, SOMETIMES THE
FAMILY CAN HELP YOU.
AT THIS POINT IF ANYONE WERE
TRYING TO HELP, AND IT WOULD BE
VERY HARD BECAUSE THE FBI IS
THERE --
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IT IS THOSE EFFORTS TO SUPPORT A
FUGITIVE THAT LEAD THE FBI RIGHT
TO THE FUGITIVE'S DOORSTEP.
THEY WILL BE LOOKING CLOSELY AT
ANY SORT OF COMMUNICATIONS,
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL INSTRUMENTS,
ALL SORTS OF THINGS THAT MIGHT
CONNECT SOMEONE IN THE COMMUNITY
VIE VA FAMILY MEMBER OR
OTHERWISE WHO MIGHT BE
SUPPORTING OR COMMUNICATING WITH
BRIAN.
THAT COULD ACTUALLY DIRECT LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO HIS LOCATION.
>> YOU KNOW, I ASKED YOU -- YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE PRESERVE AND IT
WOULD BE HARD TO HIDE THERE.
AGAIN, IF HE IS ON THE RUN, AND
WE DON'T KNOW THAT HE IS, AND WE
DON'T KNOW THAT HE IS A SUSPECT,
PER SE, IF HE'S NOT THERE, HOW
FAR AWAY COULD HE BE REASONABLY
AT THIS POINT?
IF YOU WERE IN THE FBI, WHAT
WOULD YOU BE THINKING?
.
>> WELL, CERTAINLY HE HAS TIME
ON HIS SIDE.
HE HAD SEVERAL DAYS'S LEAD ON
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT EFFORT TO
FIND HIM.
AND THAT WOULD DEFINITELY BE TO
HIS ADVANTAGE.
HOWEVER, IN THIS CASE MR.
LAUNDRIE IS WIDELY KNOWN BY THE
PUBLIC, RIGHT?
HE IS ON TELEVISION.
HIS PICTURE IS ON TELEVISION.
HIS SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS FOR THE
WEEKS LEADING UP TO THIS.
SO HE WOULD BE VERY RECOGNIZABLE
WERE HE TO LEAVE THE RESERVE AND
TRY TO MAKE A RUN FOR IT, AS WE
SAY, ON THE ECONOMY JUST THROUGH
LOCAL SOCIETY AROUND WHERE HE
LIVED.
>> YOU HEAR A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY
HE HAD A HEAD START BEFORE THE
FBI STARTED LOOKING.
IS THAT ACTUALLY SOMETHING YOU
THINK IS REAL?
>> I THINK HE DID.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THE FAMILY
DIDN'T EVEN TELL LAW ENFORCEMENT
HE WAS GONE UNTIL THE 17th.
THEY SAID HE LEFT THE PREVIOUS
TUESDAY, THE 14th.
SO IF YOU THINK OF IT, THEY
DON'T START LOOKING FOR HIM
UNTIL THAT FRIDAY OR SATURDAY.
AND HE'S BEEN GONE SINCE
TUESDAY.
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD HEAD START
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
HOWEVER, AS I SAID, WITH A